when we started working on the PvP mode
for Ghost Recon wildlands we knew we
wanted to create something different a
tense and thrilling game of tactical
team play taking co-op to the next level
today
we are proud to reveal the first Intel
on the free upcoming PvP mode for Ghost
Recon wildlands those were our objective
with ghost war was to build upon the
main games elements of co-op team play
and open tactical gameplay ghost war is
a 4v4 team deathmatch experience for two
teams of highly specialized combatants
fight in wide open environments you can
choose among a variety of classes that
you can upgrade with many different
perks each class has a specific role to
play with its own strengths and
weaknesses you and your team have to
carefully design the best combination of
play styles to take down your opponents
based on locations from the main game
the areas of conflict are wide and open
and offer plenty of opportunities and
threats through mountains deserts the
jungles or forests the terrains weathers
and times of day will push you to adapt
to the situation in ghost war new game
mechanics including a suppression system
and sound markers will deepen the
tactical options available to the player
all of these elements will make team
play communication and strategic skills
more crucial than ever in the middle of
the battleground your choices will have
real consequences should you try to
revive your friend or mark the enemy
sniper will you risk giving away your
position by shooting or lay down a trap
near the Recon antenna and when you're
the last man standing will you have what
it takes to find a way to prevail we
cannot wait for you to be able to try
out the free ghost for PvP mode for
Ghost Recon wildlands check out Ghost
Recon comm for more information on
ghosts war including more intel on the
classes in the coming weeks we're also
beginning a series of beta tests to
balance the game so stay tuned we look
forward to seeing you on the battlefield
lair this summer